[Music]
we were talking about Canada on the last
thing I have to ask you is the Queen's
Jubilee a big deal to Canadians it is it
is you know I I'm an order of Canada
that's it's like Canadian knighthood but
I know enough about me I want to hear
about you and know it is a big deal we
love the Queen we love like thought you
were serious yeah no I want to hear
about he's in Madagascar 3 he's
especially with you he plays Mort yeah
he's hilarious in this film it's really
good and well you is it you have the
perfect face for animation oh thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Broadway no I
what was your credit ween you know 60
years in the throne we love the Queen
and we love William and Kate I think
that you guys like the Canadians love
her well you know you that they're just
you know William and Kate are like the
the British version of American royalty
it's yeah like they're like Brad and
Angelina if Brad and Angelina worn a
huge drain on the economy the rumor is
that there is definitely going to be the
pitter-patter of little feet around
Buckingham really yes because an Lloyd
Webber is going to be night
[Applause]
[Music]
like I like a man like I show up if
there's not gonna be a drumroll and a
beautiful little pitter-patter thing I
walked right in it was a buzz saw
don't you love animation though I love
animations because you can do it in your
underwear as opposed to this show where
I never wear under you know I notice
when you go all the way when we hugged
it occurred to me I yeah I do animation
it must be nice said look I don't know
the best pipes and the business let's
face it no I really don't like this new
look what new look with you you've
changed the hair right I don't think I
have no listen I think you have a great
foot why have you never done an animated
movie because there's no character they
need that sounds like me you know and
three I have a very distinctive voice
people hear my voice they just know it's
me wherever I am when I call in shielded
borough lives but it didn't stop him he
became iconic why are you yelling at me
not yelling I tried to make me see my
point of view I would love to do
animation I understand it seriously the
Hollywood doesn't watch
I mean it just dawned on me that's the
answer yes no they were very nice they
had Alicia Silverstone come in and
preach you my food before every take
this is a very understanding
I do it's a stretch how do you uh how
did you prepare how did you prepare for
the sea lion roll well I mean first of
all you I spent a little time with the
sea lion never met a sea lion my first
experience delicious my beloved dog
Reggie 13 years old very very so you
look at how an animal behaves and you
kind of get even if it's a dog my I have
the heaviest dog the fattest dog right
he's a fat dog that he not only drinks
but he eats from the toilet bowl this is
home
dog that's really fat this dog even the
worms in his stool have type-2 diabetes
because it's cable I can say this one
last one oh yeah how fat is this dog he
he licks his balls with a side of slaw
these cheap shows
[Laughter]